unless you've legit been living
somewhere in a cave right now which
actually sounds kind of nice given the
state of the world you definitely know
the name Kylie or I guess we should say
Kylie Jenner legally in light of the
lawsuit from the OG Queen Kylie who sued
Jenner for attempting to trademark her
name hashtag team Minogue but anyway in
2019 Kylie was named the world's
youngest self-made billionaire at age
21. and whether you like her or hate her
the girl knows how to work
she's now a mama to a reality TV star
and an overwhelmingly successful
business owner of Kylie Cosmetics
Kylie's skin and Kylie baby she's a busy
girl and as part of the Kardashian
Jenner Clan everyone and their
grandmother wants to know a billionaire
25 year old eats in a day I'd be lying
if I said I wasn't curious too hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like one of the most successful
entrepreneurs of Our Generation Kylie
Jenner but as usual I will be dressing
it up Abby's style and turning it into
hunger crushing combos that I actually
want to eat now a quick disclaimer that
this diet was compiled from a random
Harper's Bazaar interview and it doesn't
necessarily give us insight into Kylie's
diet every day over time not that it
matters of course because I will just be
using these alleged meals as a template
for teaching gent nutrition and for
inspiring what I decide to make for
myself this is just what I ate on a
random day and is not meant to be copied
or recommended as how you should eat as
always speak to a registered dietitian
about your unique needs before we get
into the video we're going to play a
little game called Abby's daily hunger
crushing combo so I've had a very busy
day and I'm hitting that 3 P.M energy
dip and I feel like I need a little
something something so let's build a
Hunger crushing combo so I've got some
really yummy crunchy mango chips for
some antioxidants and some extra fiber
we got some pistachios here for some
healthy fats plus some Fiber and some
extra protein and I'm gonna have a bill
bar puff for my protein as you guys know
I love Bill bars because they come in a
ton of different tasty flavors and they
taste like real chocolate because they
are made with chocolate but they pack a
ton of protein like this bar right here
has 17 grams amazing so this is the
perfect hunger crushing combo snack to
get me to the dinner Time Rush without a
hangry meltdown
um
so if you watch how built by yourself
check out my link in the description and
use my promo code abbysharp15 to get 15
off of your order
I'm excited about this one I don't know
like
I feel like Carly's up there as one of
my favorite Kardashians what's your
who's your favorite Kardashian Brody
Jenner or Jenner I think Kendall yes
because of the way she cuts cucumbers
Fair like she cuts them properly which
is great be careful because I cut I
nipped myself the other day I don't know
I'm kind of scared I know yeah she's got
good technique
um but I I can't handle like her she's
got some serious health anxiety going on
but Kylie I mean she seems like the most
private from watching the show she seems
like she doesn't she doesn't want to get
involved in the drama and I can
appreciate that so I'm excited about
this day
um let's see how she starts her day so
the first thing I eat or drink when I
wake up is probably my bone broth it's
mixed with like lavender and lemon or my
celery juice so I have like a whole
drawer in my refrigerator just raw
celery I'm starting to take back what I
said there
um because obviously I don't have a
drawer full of celery in my head house
because celery makes me bloated as and
is really only a vessel for peanut
butter as far as I'm concerned Abby
please explain the whole celery juice
thing yeah if you have IBS or a
sensitive gut celery juice is probably
not gonna feel so good it's loaded with
fodmaps which can cause severe digestive
distress and unlike with the so-called
medical medium suggests there's nothing
magical about it it doesn't bind toxins
to flush them out or strengthen bile to
kill off disease it's
99.99999999 water and all water helps
you detox the only potential reason that
celery juice may seem to detox you
faster is because the FODMAP irritants
are giving you the runs I've been in a
really good place with my IBS lately and
I'm not feeling like poking the diarrhea
bear with some like nonsensical Wellness
Trend that a psychic recommended so I
got got myself a green juice from the
store this one has orange juice
pineapple juice those are the first
ingredients because I think that helps
it taste like something baby spinach or
organic baby spinach they don't probably
the the non-organic so it's cheaper and
some kale all right so that adds the
green let's give her a go
oh my God
I guess I need the spinach
and then you can add a Popeye reference
[Music]
oh she thick I'm not sure I'm gonna
enjoy that
tastes like pineapple juice that's green
and I can get behind that as for the
bone broth like I'm a little less
enthused about that one I don't want to
yuck anyone's yum because I know this is
you know very traditional in a lot of
cultures but the idea of having a cup of
warm Savory salty broth first thing in
the morning before even coffee
is a no for me Abby is there any benefit
to this Wellness ritual so bone broth is
rich in collagen Protein Plus
micronutrients like calcium iron
magnesium and potassium so it's
definitely a nutritious food now there
is some animal research on bone broth
linking it to improved gut health and
some early research linking the
glutamine amino acid in it to improving
gut permeability but we still need a lot
more quality research to confirm the
specific role of bone broth and how much
you would physically need to consume to
see any unique benefits more obvious
benefit of bone broth is that it's rich
in gelatin protein which research
suggests specifically does increase
satiety Factor AKA it can be a great
component of the hunger crushing combo
honestly I think that bone broth is a
really nutritious ingredient so I pretty
much always have a carton of it in the
pantry but I prefer to incorporate it
into recipes to like bump up the flavor
and the protein and the nutrition we're
rather than just like sipping it in a
cup like tea so yeah I'm gonna shelf
this one for now literally and then come
back to it later on in the day and try
to like incorporate it into a meal or
snack all right let's get to the drinks
that I actually want to eat or drink
whatever but I love
um peach tea and I do love my coffee I
do a Vanilla Ice latte with oat milk all
right I love me some peach tea and I
also love coffee so this is a win-win
double fisting drink situation and I'm
here for it let's we'll just get to it
smells good
and up the old nasal passage
all right I like this combo we got some
energy we got some calm some good
balance the Ying the Yang the
all right let's try it
hot
now I don't have taste buds
do you think you'd learn the first go
still Still's too hot we'll wait all
right what are we having to eat there
Kylie stormie and I usually eat
breakfast together she likes fruit
blueberries she loves turkey bacon oh
she loves Bagels love this family
breakfast and these are pretty much all
foods that my family loves as well and I
don't actually buy a whole lot of bacon
turkey or otherwise but I do think a lot
of people will opt for the turkey
thinking that it's inherently a lot
healthier than the straight up pork what
do you think Gabby I say that's mainly
Health washing and really good marketing
I mean turkey bacon has about 25 fewer
calories per ounce compared to regular
pork bacon but they have virtually the
same amount of sodium and some turkey
Bacons even have a little bit less
protein turkey bacon is often a little
more heavily processed than pork since
making bacon at a poultry requires
taking bits of the carcass and then
putting it through a sieve under high
pressure and then combining it with
starches and other fats to make like a
bacon shape pork bacon especially the
higher quality ones are simply cut from
the belly and preserved now I don't
think that either option is inherently
unhealthy or bad nor do I think that
either is a miraculous health food so I
say choose your favorite variety and
enjoy in moderation so I ended up
getting like Canadian bacon or female
bacon back bacon whatever you want to
call it just mainly because my family
prefers that but it is also typically
higher in protein and lower in saturated
fat and salt compared to typical strip
bacon and it's easy to cook but I do
feel like I'm still gonna need a little
bit extra protein in this meal to like
make it super satisfying so I'm gonna
upgrade Kylie's breakfast and add a
couple scrambled eggs and I'm just going
to do it really super easy style in the
microwave let's do it I got these eggs
at the farmer's market and like look at
this one I've never seen an egg with
like a little lump
weird
interesting melange of colors so let's
see what they look different inside
oh geez
and I got a show
this is the trick to getting the shells
out you got to use the big shell the
mama shell to get the baby show see
oh she's a beaut look look gorgeous
shell oh heating pan fry okay we'll pan
fry this
foreign
little avocado in the fridge so I'm
going to smash that down first just as
like a little healthy fats
do a couple slices of tomato
we've got our egg with a little cheese
action our female oh yeah
and this is like a curry ketchup it is
it just hits different the everything
sauce they call it it's like so good
little smash attack
oh she's gonna be messy and apparently
Kylie likes a little fruit on the side
she mentions blueberries I'm sure stormy
likes grapes because what child doesn't
like grapes like grapes grapes like are
really the Queen in the kid fruit
hierarchy because they're juicy they're
super sweet they're like kind of
forbidden for the first few years
because they're a major choking hazard
but we love to see it unlike a good firm
grape Brody all right let's recap we got
fiber rich carbs in our bagel and our
fruit plus some extra fiber in our
avocado healthy fats in the avocado
cheese and the Egg plus lots of protein
in the female bacon and the Egg as well
I'm pretty excited about this
um I probably should cut it in half but
I'm just gonna go for it living on the
edge
[Music]
oh yeah
food Club okay so I feel like we got a
good solid breakfast and I've got lots
of energy now to work out let's see what
Kylie does for exercise I never find
myself in a gym I find myself on the
floor of my bedroom looking up on like
Google or Pinterest like workouts and
doing abs lunges squats love a good
YouTube video workout feels like a good
excuse to bust out some Sydney Cummings
let's do it
foreign
[Music]
thing every day but I do love like lemon
chicken with vegetables sometimes I'll
make myself some tacos today at the
shoot I ordered a steak burrito and some
rice some enchiladas I was feeling
Mexican food Vibes today it really just
depends I feel like Mexican takeout food
has gotten a really bad reputation maybe
because a lot of kind of like
Americanized Mexican dishes are
typically deep fried but traditionally I
think there's actually a lot of
nutrition and balance going on Brody do
you want Chipotle definitely well let's
do it
love a good reason not to have to cook
every single meal from scratch in a day
because I never do that just an FYI
all right oh
definitely not the most instagramable
meal but I promise you it'll hit the
spot so I opted to go with a salad from
Chipotle because I actually find that
you know you get a little bit of
everything this way you get your vegan
with the greens I added lots of the
fajita veg for some extra fiber we got
some rice in here as well for some extra
carbs plus the black beans and the
chicken in there for some protein loaded
her up with some cheese and I guess I
got queso Blanca which I didn't order
but I'm excited about regardless and I
always opt for guac and they were pretty
generous with the portion size so I'm
excited about that
let's get in there it's messy but it's
good
it's so good
um Chipotle is like one of my favorite
takeout spots oh spicy too that's so
yummy all right it's snack o'clock that
is scary what are we having Kylie I will
have to admit that I am a big snacker
barbecue lays chili juice Fritos extra
cheesy goldfish I don't usually buy this
flavor extreme cheddar check it out
stream cheddar
but I'm here for anything that's extreme
we gotta live on the edge we gotta
switch it up we gotta we gotta feel
something sometimes and if extreme
cheddar goldfish is gonna spice up my
life I'm here for it so we're gonna
combine a few of Kylie's carrot snacks
into a hunger crushing combo this is
gonna be dangerous
oh but she's a beaut look at that
it is pomegranate season and
pomegranates are one of the most
delicious
fruits of life
let's put a little snack plate together
all right so I got some pistachios
healthy fats fiber protein all the
things oh they salty salt and vinegar
what
you know this is an instacart surprise
and usually they're not so pleasant but
I didn't order this
but I'm excited this is what I got all
right statues down careful careful
oh no
seeds oh my goodness it's like a murder
scene it's like the blood spatter
pattern
blood spatter pattern blood spatter
pattern is that the right term where are
my true crime fans at blood spatter
patterns blood blood spatter splatter
splatter so I know about that I'm
basically like I'm like an honorary FBI
agent crime scene investigator Abby
sharp Bert Macklin FBI
this is a lot of work guys a lot of work
this is why you usually I just buy the
pre-plucked arrows okay that's that's
enough for me we'll just load up on the
goldfish is that what that's for I love
it
[Applause]
um
one to ten one being not so extreme and
ten being extremely extreme I give this
a 9.5
stream cheddar
it's good
all right you just see the salt on each
one of these little these little fishies
come to me baby
all right got fiber Protein healthy fats
extra fiber antioxidants and a little
fun extreme cheddar was not to love all
right eeny meeny miny mo catch a fishy
by the toe iffy hollers let them go eeny
meeny miny cheated well
all right I'm gonna go get a little work
done and I'll meet you on the flip side
all right Kylie I'm hungry let's find
out what's for dinner lemon chicken and
white rice
and vegetables kale salad okay so I
found like a copycat version of Kylie
Jenner's lemon chicken so we're gonna
kind of like go with that not sure if
this is legitimately how she makes it
but it sounded easy and I like easy so
I've got some chicken tenders here I
believe they used chicken breasts but
this is gonna cook a lot faster so throw
those down now
foreign
so I got some lemon and herbs blend
that's going to go down
let me just see if there's salt in this
yep number one ingredient perfect so I
could skip the extra seasoning then they
seem to put just like a ton of this like
lemon herb marinade on top kind of like
as the sauce love love a quickie cheater
recipe
they don't know how much but I don't
want to like be gross okay that's good
and then they throw some asparagus on
top as well so we'll throw that there
and then some salt and pepper maybe
I need some like sauce or something
maybe the marinade has oil in it yeah
put some of that too
a little of the herb seasoning
okay so we're going to throw this into
an oven see how it goes all right so I
rinsed my rice really really well and to
double down on the flavor and the
protein I'm gonna cook my rice in bone
broth instead of just straight up water
I figured you'd expect me to swap the
white rice for brown but I actually
typically will always choose white and
I'll tell you why for one I just like it
better so that's most important but two
brown rice has only like one measly gram
or Fiber compared to White plus it has
eighty percent more inorganic arsenic
now white bus money and sushi rice tends
to be the lowest arsenic options for
Rice which also happens to be my
favorite varieties anyway so I will
usually choose white if I have a choice
I don't think this is something to
stress over for most adults consuming
rice in moderation but if Kylie is
feeding rice regularly to her kids along
with other rice products like rice cakes
or rice puffs I would continue to choose
white more often and if you do opt for a
higher arsenic rice just make sure to
rinse the rice really really well and
then cook it in excess water and then
drain it when you're done okay let's go
over this folks we got carbs in our rice
we've got protein teen in our chicken
plus a little extra protein in the bone
broth that I use to cook the rice in
great little hack we got fiber rich veg
here plus some healthy fats that I added
with the pine nuts I mean it looks
pretty good and was pretty simple too
and I love that we could cook the
chicken with the asparagus I love a
double duty meal let's give it a go
mmm
and like super juicy mmm
I love that great idea
Let's do an asparagus
asparagus and lemon
match made in heaven good job Kylie okay
you guys know I'm big on bedtime snacks
I literally cannot go to bed until I get
like a little something something before
I hit the hay so let's take a look at
what Kylie has I avoid late night
cravings because I lock myself in my
bedroom and I turn on my TV I get really
comfortable and I pre-slice an apple by
my bed since I'm really comfortable I'll
be too lazy probably to go down to the
kitchen so I'm gonna my only choice is
this apple okay this is by far the worst
part of the whole interview locking
yourself in your bedroom with just an
Apple so that you don't eat anything
else is problematic
Abby what do you think if you need to
lock yourself or specific Foods up to
prevent yourself from eating them it's
probably time to re-evaluate your
relationship with food are you eating
enough in the day to prevent yourself
from thinking obsessively about food at
night are you allowing yourself the food
that you actually crave and want to eat
locking yourself in your room with a low
calorie snack when you're thinking about
eating something else or eating more
simply perpetuates body distrust and is
a setup for a binge when you somehow
Escape your room because we're grown-ass
adults and we can do that so as most of
you guys know I have insomnia so I don't
really sleep well on a good night and if
I do wake up in the middle of the night
which I often do and I'm awake for like
a long period of time the last thing I
want is to get super ravenous and hungry
it just like wakes me up and stimulates
me more
so I actually purposefully have my
bedtime snack like here in the kitchen
um just to make sure that I feel super
satisfied and satiated before I head up
to start my bedtime routine and just
because of my history with insomnia I
usually like err on the side of eating a
little bit more rather than eating a
little bit less just to be extra sure
that I'm not gonna wake up hungry
or a book
so just out of like a pure Act of
rebellion against the dye culture
display that we just witnessed I'm gonna
take Kylie's apple and turn it into a
hunger crushing combo I actually want to
eat let's make like a really super
simple microwave baked apple this is
something my mom used to make for me all
the time all right so I got a little
melted butter there we're gonna add in
some oats a little brown sugar
poop
poop I have some raisins here and lots
of pecans and maybe a little ham cards
why not
[Applause]
all right we got a little
seasoning here eggnog found that and I
was like this is amazing I don't even
know what's in this nutmeg cinnamon and
some natural flavor it
smells amazing and I'm gonna add a
splashy splash of maple
that'll do just to bring it all together
all right any little dishy dish
in
packer in
a little extra drizzle
I'm gonna put this in the microwave
until
well until it's soft enough to eat oh
that looks way better than just an apple
eaten by itself in solitude a little
dollop of Greek yogurt
it's eggnog that back up
and this is a fork at night situation so
you cannot just like lock yourself in
your bedroom and dream of something
better than just a straight up Apple
um
um
it's so good guys we got fiber on our
apple and our oats and our nuts we got
protein in the nuts and the hemp seeds
and the yogurt we got healthy fats in
like everything including the nuts and
the hemp parts and the yogurt all the
good stuff and it tastes amazing like
Kylie take note so with the exception of
the morning beverage ritual and the Fort
Knox bedtime routine situation I would
say it was not an offensive day of
eating I feel like I got in a lot of my
personal favorite foods and I learned a
really delicious new chicken recipe that
was actually pretty easy to pull off and
I got chipotle so I'd say with the mods
that I made in a being a pretty
satisfying day but guys I would love to
hear from you what you thought of this
video if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on Whose diet you'd like me to try next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]